so our reddit discussion forum is
humming right along approaching 3000
subscribers lots of great political
discussions going on among the
subscribers at david pakman.com slash
read it a few discussions from this week
that i want to show you
countless threads about the Milo you
nopales situation one talking about his
appearance on the Bill Maher program
which had as of this morning over forty
comments and climbing and another mile
oh eun-ah police-related thread about
the press conference that he gave I
guess at this point it was a couple of
days ago there were like 10 to 12
different Milo related threads I won't
show you all of them
but clearly an issue that one contingent
one cadre of our viewership is very very
interested in another issue discussed on
our reddit discussion forum at david
pakman.com slash read it is the concept
of how to deal with the madness in other
words a a lot of people are really not
feeling too too good about feeling too
well i guess it would be i want to speak
i I don't I don't know I think it's
feeling too well anyway about the
current state of our political system
they're depressed about Trump media
coverage etc and this conversation was
just getting going as of this morning
but I think it's an interesting topic
how to deal with the political madness
also from our reddit discussion forum I
posted that I'm thinking about doing a
reddit AMA and asked me anything and I
was collecting suggestions about how to
make it as effective and a sort of
productive as possible one idea was I
should actually be live-streaming myself
on YouTube as I do the questions in the
reddit AMA I think that's a really good
idea and if other people in our audience
have suggestions for how to make it a
success I'm all get all years Pat I
can't wait for this I mean there's just
so many questions I can't wait to ask
you right under fake fake a troll
accounts that I know you've been
creating quietly over the last several
months okay and then lastly scandal has
ripped through David Pakman show studios
yesterday on the program vegan producer
Pat alluded to actually
they had just admitted to using a Keurig
machine for coffee and the the
perception from some was that I was
quote visibly shaken when you made that
admission is there any people are
actually there's a poll going on at
david pakman.com slash read it about
whether you should be punished on air
for that admission but i think you have
something you want to add to that first
off this is a big scandal i mean there's
a press conference waiting for me
outside this couldn't end up taking me
down but i don't think i was very clear
i only use the pods if someone else buys
it for me ah generally i use this
plastic mold and I scoop ground coffee
into it each day so I'm really not
wasting too much plastic and you could
say maybe the Keurig doesn't make the
coffee taste very good right I'm willing
to hear all that but I think this
controversy should just go away
so you unilaterally reject the pollution
and waste allegations in terms of your
Keurig usage essentially but I still
feel obligated to apologize if I
offended anyone
oh yeah well duh with an apology if I
offended anyone we've we've we've we've
I can't believe Pat's going there now I
can see another series of reddit threads
about that okay but seriously great
discussions happening on reddit david
pakman.com slash re d di t